Microsoft is very interested in healthcare problems
because the healthcare industry has got a lot of
technology, a lot of data and yet we feel that we are not
making the best use of that technology and that data.
Novartis approached us; they're very interested in the
ability to assess and diagnose the progression of multiple
sclerosis, which is a very tricky disease to try and assess.
Multiple Sclerosis is a disease of the central nervous system
and it can affect people’s everyday lives, so it can affect their
balance, their motor abilities, their ability to walk, to eat.
It can also affect cognitive abilities and vision.
We saw a real possibility to use all of the expertise that we
have in the building around machine learning and computer
vision and the design of user experiences to bring all of those
different disciplines together, to provide some data that's
going to help the expert make a better assessment.
The role of machine learning in Assess MS is to find an
automated way to classify the patient's condition, given the
a certain set of movements. So the goal is simply to
standardize.
Multiple Sclerosis is currently assessed by a Neurologist
using a clinical standardized rating scale.
So they might ask a patient to stretch out their hands
touch their nose, walk for five meters. And this is
where technology has a real strength.
Assess MS System provides a consistent, quantified measure
of motor ability over time.
As the disease progresses, you can see stronger
and stronger impairments on the motors skills and the machine
learning basically just tries to figure out where do
certain signatures start for which category
and how do they develop as you cross the
boundary to the next category?
At the moment the Assess MS project is focused around
providing this consistent measure in clinical trials.
We worked with a team at Novartis Pharma AG
who helped us understand what kinds of things are needed
in clinical trials and how it is that we go about partnering
with clinics.
It requires multiple stakeholders and what we've been
able to do in this collaboration is work with university
hospitals, Microsoft Research, as well as our own
Novartis research teams, to bring together the best talent
needed to completely change the paradigm in how we
assess MS patients' disability progression.
We're not trying to replace the Neurologist or the
Nurse. What we're trying to do instead is to very much
bolster or augment the kinds of expertise that they already have. It's there to really help
the doctor give a consistent measurement over time to help the patient to make the best
decisions they can about their treatment.